[Música]
en nuestro tema del día hablamos de la
previa a la conferencia de la onu sobre
el clima con 26 que comienza este
domingo en glasgow en escocia líderes
mundiales activistas por el clima
expertos en crisis climática van a
discutir la hoja de ruta a seguir en los
próximos años para tratar de así frenar
el calentamiento global y reducir las
emisiones de carbono lo lograremos esa
es por supuesto la gran pregunta la
pregunta del millón por ello quiero
saludar en este momento a carla más
wolfensohn ella es asesora la climate
action network gracias carla por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo américa
empecemos preguntándole qué podemos
esperar de esta con 26 muchas gracias
por la invitación y por tenernos con
ustedes media en esta sesión
la cope 16 bueno como ustedes saben se
puso un año
en un contexto en el que hay una
pandemia global y que ha aumentado
significativamente las presiones de
acción en materia de acción climática
precisamente en un momento de
recuperación económica que debe de ser
verde que debe ser sostenible que debe
ser inclusiva y que debe considerar a
nuevos cambios de paradigma es dicho eso
que lo que esperamos para la con 26 yo
quizás lo resumiría en tres grandes
elementos ambición climática la vamos a
entender como el refuerzo nuevamente de
la ciencia el compromiso de los países
de acelerar sus planes de mitigación
entendidos como los nrc solos en las
construcciones nacionalmente
determinadas una conversación muy
importante que quedar es cómo vamos a
atender el mecanismo de mercado del
mercado conocido como artículo 6
y cómo vamos a acelerar este proceso
continuo de aumento de la ambición para
cerrar la brecha que tenemos actual de
ambición en materia de mitigación y para
cumplir el objetivo que establece la
corte de parís de 1.5 todos esos
elementos enmarcados en gran componente
de ambición es otro componente muy
importante para los 26 en el tema del
financiamiento financiamiento climático
un elemento que los países
entendidos como industrializados o
neutralizado quizás en la jerga de la
convención desarrollados y no
desarrollados
tienen un compromiso de reunir 100 mil
millones de dólares al 2020 y del 2021
al 2025 de manera anual no llegamos a
esa meta los países no están cumpliendo
con ese compromiso y eso tiene un
impacto directo no solamente la
capacidad de acciones de los países de
américa latina o por el psuv global sino
que además
en el nivel de confianza
y de posibilidad de articular acciones
entero
es que carla eso le quería decir vimos
la cumbre de parís de 2015 no mítica con
todos estos acuerdos y tal que tanto se
ha hecho y no no sea eso no se ha hecho
mucho lo necesario para poder tratar de
frenar esto entonces que va a cambiar en
esta con 26 realmente también hay otra
pregunta sirve en estas cumbres del
clima para para tomar acciones concretas
innecesarias ya además el primer
ministro británico boris johnson dijo
que no se haría mucho en esta
competición entonces para qué se siguen
celebrando
mucha perspectiva y mi perspectiva
personal también es que estas cumbres
son marcos globales donde es sumamente
relevante que todos los países dentro de
este ejercicio multilateral tengamos
metas y visiones comunes y que aquellas
podamos luego bajar e implementar en
nuestros territorios claramente estas
grandes directrices globales no tienen
ningún impacto si es que los países y
sus y los gobiernos y los estados en
particular nos bajan estos estos
compromisos a políticas nacionales es
necesario que todo lo que aquí se
acuerda tenga una implementación muy
concreta a nivel nacional y eso es el
gran trabajo el gran trabajo es que todo
lo que acá se dice que normalmente
citando a directa escuchar siempre que
puede ser un gran blablabla tengo un
correlato muy directo en cómo los países
diseñan sus planes de desarrollo cómo se
asignan los presupuestos nacionales
donde se dirigen etcétera entonces sí es
muy importante que estos marcos globales
sean
pero además y nosotros vamos a hacer
esfuerzos de incidencia política en
nuestros países para que se cumpla
carla pero también por ejemplo el primer
ministro de australia scott morrison
primero no iba a asistir ya después dijo
que se iba a asistir y ya dijo que no
estaba claro si su país que en mejor
dicho no iba a alcanzar para 2030
rebajar en las emisiones de metano que
tan compromiso que tanto tienen que
comprometerse estos países
industrializados los más contaminantes
para realmente hacer algo porque también
si ya van con esta premisa de que pues
no se va a hacer nada y no lo vamos a
lograr entonces que queda para los demás
muchas gracias por tu pregunta de hecho
australia siempre ha sido un país
cómo decirlo emblemático es en las
negociaciones por esa postura
bien ligado al negacionismo bien ligado
al status quo que ligado a la discusión
no siempre ha cumplido ese rol y tensa
un poco la posibilidad de avanzar quizás
hacia
la descarbonización el abandono de los
combustibles fósiles
xcel entonces solamente digo eso porque
efectivamente se dan estas dinámicas de
poder entre los países y en particular
australia ha tenido un rol ha cumplido
un rol de de tensionar el avance de la
negociación sur pero eso no quiere decir
que hayan acciones que estén pasando
incluso a nivel de australia en los
territorios para avanzar en materia de
acción climática vemos por ejemplo que
hay toda una agenda de actores no
estatales como se le conoce dentro del
marco de la convención que si está
avanzando y que tiene mucho poder de
transformación
no quiero despedirse esta conversación o
carla sin preguntarle el papel de
américa latina en esta cumbre tenemos
más o menos minuto y medio para terminar
de conversar
muchas gracias bueno américa latina como
una región
emblemática donde aún tenemos una
elevada dependencia de nuestra
naturaleza y abriga tinas de un rol muy
importante que jugar en la preservación
de sus ecosistemas estratégicos y aquí
yo me centraría en el amazonas el
amazonas es un ecosistema estratégico
para el mundo entero y la protección de
este este este pulmón o este corazón es
vital donde la moratoria a la
explotación y la extracción de
combustibles fósiles es una señal clara
que los países deben de dar en la
capital